Mihawk took Zoro in because of Luffy.
Have you ever be so bored that you went out
of your way to start beef with a Yonko?
Well, me neither.
However, this guy has.
Mihawk is an incredibly interesting character
in the story for a number of reasons.
As the strongest swordsman, his strength and
position in the hierarchy of the One Piece
world, are probably one of the most heatedly
discussed topics in the fandom at this point.
And while there are probably just as many
people who find this debate pointless as those
who blow it way out of proportion, Mihwak's
power actually is a big part of his character.
Because even though he might not seem like
the type, being one of the most stoic and
serious characters in the story, Mihawk has
a surprisingly interesting character arc,
starting all the way back at the Baratie and
coming to a close with him taking Zoro in
as his student.
And so, even though Mihawk rarely actively
appears in the story, he actually plays a
really important role for the One Piece world
building overall, but especially so for Zoro
and his journey towards becoming the strongest
swordsman in the world.
So, how did Mihawk change as a character during
and after Marineford?
How strong is he really?
What's the deal with him and Perona?
And will he fight Zoro and Shanks again in
the future?
This is the story of the strongest swordsman,
rival to Shanks and former warlord of the
sea.
This is the story Dracule Mihawk.
At his introduction early on in the story,
Mihawk serves as a
Sign-post of how strong people in the world
of One Piece truly are.
As a fellow warlord, he brilliantly sets the
stakes for the Baroque works saga and the
fight against Crocodile.
I already talked a lot about all the symbolism
that is associated with Mihawk in my Scene
analysis of his fight with Zoro in Baratie,
so if you are interested in that, I suggest
you check that video out afterwards.
To sum it up, like most swordsmen in the story,
Mihawk has a very strong religious theme going,
giving him the appearance of a Spanish inquisitor.
This mostly serves to show the duality of
both his strong dedication to his beliefs
and creed, while at the same time highlighting
his violent, unforgiving and strict side as
well, just as the Catholic church used to
be, during The Inquisition.
This creed that Mihawk follows, is not Christianity
however, but the Bushido, the path of the
samurai, that Zoro also follows, although
approached through a Buddhist lens, while
shanks represents nordic mythology and its
values and beliefs.
Long story short, swordsmanship, and by that
I mean REAL swordsmanship is a sort of religion
in the world of One Piece.
And only true believers and followers can
rise in the ranks of the very best.
This serves as the framework for the interactions
and relationships Mihawk has with Zoro and
Shanks.
All have quite different beliefs, values and
powers, but they all respect the Bushido,
and thus are worthy opponents, when it comes
to sword fighting that is.
This is regardless of their actual power level.
The reason why Mihawk suddenly started respecting
Zoro and treating him as a worthy opponent
is not because Zoro suddenly became as strong
as him, but because he demonstrated his will
to follow the path of the swordsman to
the death, and Major spoiler from the manga,
please skip ahead 10 seconds if you aren't
caught up, of course by that will, I also
mean Zoro's conqueror’s haki that Mihawk
most likely saw when he used the three thousand
worlds against him.
We have this short moment, as Zoro launches
his attack where Mihawk is clearly shocked
by this reveal, as it serves as the ultimate
proof of Zoro’s will and potential to make
it to the top.
So how is it that Mihawk went from seeing
Zoro as a potential future rival, to becoming
his mentor throughout the time skip?
Let's look at Mihawk's surprisingly deep character
arc.
Writing a great character arc is actually
pretty damn hard.
And as with all new skills you want to learn
things, it helps having someone explain it
to you in great detail.
And that is exactly what Skillshare is all
about.
Skillshare is an online learning community
with thousands of inspiring classes for creative
and curious people covering pretty much any
topic you might ever want to learn about.
Be it starting a YouTube channel or how to
make your very own Manga.
I've been using Skillshare for quite sometime,
mostly to improve my work here on YouTube.
For example, if you write yourself, I recommend
this excellent course on character arcs.
But It can really be anything.
For example I personally have really enjoyed
this course on knife skills by Elana Karp
recently, so I can slice my Onions in true
Mihawk fashion now.
And look, there is even a class on Bladesmithing.
If you also love learning new skills, then
you should definitely give Skillshare a try.
Not only is it pretty affordable, with under
10 bucks per month for an annual subscription,
but the first 1000 people to use my link in
the description will get a free trial of Skillshare
Premium so you can try it for yourself.
But, now back to my fellow knife master.
Mihawk's perspective on the central moral
theme of One Piece, freedom, is that the best
thing is to be a lone wolf, bound by no-one
and seeking out other wolves to test his strength.
Or I guess in his case it's actually a lone
hawk.
One might even say he’s a me-hawk.
The major turning point for Mihawk was the
war at Marineford.
Before the war, we get introduced to him as
an extremely self-centered person.
He is pretty much the only strong person out
there operating completely without a crew
or any other people around to support him.
He is literally a one-man crew, that sails
the seas bored out of his mind as he has no-one
to test his ridiculous strength on.
This becomes especially clear in his relationship
with Shanks.
Regardless of Haki, Shanks was powerful enough
as a swordsman alone to spar evenly with Mihawk,
leading to the legendary rivalry between them.
No doubt Mihawk came looking for Shanks quite
often to have a duel.
But when Shanks sacrifices his arm for Luffy
and inspiring him to become a pirate, Mihawk
doesn't care at all about his motivations
and the reasons, he simply sees Shanks sacrificing
his strong sword arm as an insult to their
rivalry and doesn't even bother to draw his
sword against him.
Shanks, the only man who was able to excite
Mihawk, gave up on being a top tier swordsman
for a mere kid.
Given that Shanks has ridiculous haki abilities,
he probably doesn't care about that though,
and their rivalry turned into a sort of friendship.
However, that left Mihawk with absolutely
no-one to rival with and test his skills on
and he ended up so bored and aimless, that
he chased after powerful people like Don Krieg,
just to get a bit of a kick.
This self-centered person, who only cared
about strength, would not have accepted Zoro’s
show of throwing away his pride as a Swordsman
by bowing to him.
This is basically what Shanks did in Mihawk’s
eyes.
And so it's no surprise that this proud, ridiculously
powerful swordsman, despite becoming a warlord,
was never really willing to follow the directions
of the world government.
What made the war at Marineford different,
was not the fact that he was scared of the
government’s repercussions, as we just saw,
Mihawk didn't really care at all about losing
his warlord title, no, the reason he participated
in this war, was because he would be able
to challenge Whitebeard.
The strongest man in the world vs the strongest
swordsman.
Basically Mihawk went to Marineford for a
kick – to fight the only man he believed
worth fighting.
And yet, when he showed his hand, Jozu, shielded
his captain from his attack.
It begins to dawn on Mihawk that Whitebeard
wasn't only feared because of the beast of
a person he was, but also because of all the
people he had gathered around him.
And later, the very same thing happens again
with Luffy.
Deciding to test his resolve and power again,
after already having taken an interest in
him at Baratie, more and more of Luffy’s
allies kept getting in Mihawk’s way.
At this point, Mihawk understands that the
ability of gathering allies is the greatest
power he’s seen on the seas.
And yet, his mind doesn't change here yet
completely.
When Shanks arrives to end the war, he realizes
that there are no more worthy opponents left
to fight and he leaves, Shanks is the last
person he wants to fight after he ruined their
rivalry, and of course to be fair also because
Shanks as a yonko is most likely just out
of his league when he uses his haki.
Things really only change for Mihawk after
the war, as Zoro is transported to his island.
And it is this interaction between them, that
brings Luffy's impact on Mihawk to full bloom.
Zoro is the only character, as far as we know,
who Mihawk hopes can grow to one day challenge
him.
And yet Zoro is telling him that fighting
for the self-centered greatest Swordsman pride,
something that Mihawk only cares about, does
is no longer his motivation.
Zoro wants to become the strongest swordsman
in order to help Luffy become pirate king.
At first this leaves Mihawk disgusted.
He thinks that Zoro is weak and wasn't even
strong enough to beat the monkeys on the island,
that were trying to imitate him, by the way
a really nice metaphor for what he thinks
of most other swordsmen, and he believed that
Zoro came asking him for help to get off the
island.
And yet for the very first time, these things
are now becoming personal to Mihawk with added
perspective.
When he sees that Zoro had beaten all the
monkeys and could leave whenever he wanted
to, Mihawk realizes that Zoro is asking for
help for Luffy's sake and not his own which
is why he agrees to train him.
Mihawk finally listens to Zoro and accepts
his plea given that he’s seen that fighting
for others is worthwhile in its own right
since Luffy and Whitebeard fought for Ace
and in turn very many people fought for them
as well, ultimately making his presence at
the war irrelevant, as he was never willing
to go all out anyways.
Mihawk is no longer the lone wolf, realizing
that having someone by your side to fight
for, is what gives one true freedom and purpose.
And so, the fact that he lets Perona and Zoro
stay with him on his island for two years,
forming real relationships for the first time,
is something prewar Mihawk would never have
been able to do.
And I ultimately believe that Mihawk’s character
arc would be fully completed if he ever decided